to what degree was trump involved in  planning to what degree did donald trump  know that it was going to get violent to  what degree did donald trump encourage  or want exactly what happened to happen  we have a variety of reasons to believe  including the fact that trump spoke so  positively about the rioters even as the  riot was going on on january 6th in the  recorded video statement that was  released we have every reason to believe  that he was involved and he was enjoying  it until or other than the fact that as  he said the protesters the writers the  insurrectionist looked low class which  he felt was making him look bad so the  broader context is momentum is building  in terms of the committee  we don't know  whether people speaking to the committee  are really turning on trump  but i still don't think this is going to  lead to the types of consequences you  and i would like to see